hi I'm Dave from Dave's Hot Chicken and
you can find me on bootleg kev's podcast
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here I'm gonna let you guys introduce
yourself we have the the guys behind the
best hot chicken I've ever had Dave's
Hot Chicken legendary place
I'm Arman I'm one of the founders Dave
Chef so you're Dave yeah Armon and Dave
we're Armand and Dave yeah Dave from
Dave's Hot Chicken
well let's get started like first of all
you guys are um blowing up everywhere
you guys are kind of like the
quintessential hot chicken place in
America when people come to LA and they
always ask me the rappers will be like
yo where do I go I always just send them
to Dave's on microchip I'm like I was
like you guys want some quick good [ __ ]
go to Dave's right here I'm like you
guys
um so how did you guys originally well
first of all how did you guys meet
uh we actually met on Dave's birthday so
I think we were like 13 or 14 years old
I didn't know we met through a mutual
friend and he's like I'm going to my uh
friend Dave's birthday it's like his
last name's Capuchin I'm like that's a
cool ass stand but I'm like I'll be
friends with somebody named Capuchin
right so I went to the birthday we met
and uh literally just like started
hanging out the next day yeah and ever
since then you guys been locked in yeah
we've been we've been homie since then
yeah nice and you guys are both Armenian
right yeah yeah we live close to we
lived in Hollywood at the time yeah like
five minutes away so yeah so you guys
were like kind of like already in the
same area yeah yeah yeah and uh do so
they like ever since I've met him he was
like a culinary guy right he's on the
food like you see him it's got like a
stack of like cookbooks with him and
he's like a chef yeah it was like a mad
scientist of food you know so wow so he
was definitely in it for a while uh and
uh at the time I was a aspiring actor
you know I wanted to be of course in
Hollywood you got the look I I try man I
got the look I'm lacking the talent now
I'm just kidding but um but yeah you
know so we were like uh you know we just
wanted to do business together yeah yeah
ever since we were like dude we got to
do something together make some money
like yeah that's what it was all about
yeah so food is like been your passion
cooking and stuff right so
why because I feel like you guys because
there's like a new like hot chick has
always been a thing but there's like
this new yeah like everywhere you go now
there's a hot chicken spot oh yeah
especially in the valley yeah yeah I
feel like every other corner there's a
new like you gotta have fake Dave's
popping up right right wherever you
[ __ ] go like I was just they just not
chicken um I was at the Glendale mall in
the new spot and there's a hot chicken
place I was like look at this [ __ ] is
popping up everywhere you had it too
um but um you guys are very responsible
for like a trend in like restaurants
yeah
um why hot chicken
um I mean it's a pretty crazy story I
mean yeah so
um so hot chicken uh started kind of
like we've always been a big fan of
fried chicken right right so hot chicken
kind of started getting trending in La
you know one of the chefs had a
Nashville brought it down to LA and uh
me and Dave tried it immediately I mean
we fell in love with it right we're like
dude this is so good and uh we're like
well dude you know you're like you're a
chef you know I have like a little bit
of background in marketing I'm pretty
good you know social media whatever I'm
like what if we got together and we made
a recipe and and you know what if we
tried to like get in on this trend but
uh the funny thing is like at the time
we're obviously dead broke you know Dave
is working at a restaurant that doesn't
pay anything right I'm doing acting
which doesn't pay anything right uh and
then we had a a third friend named Tommy
who I met in kindergarten so three of us
linked up we're like all right why don't
we just work on a recipe for now right
like okay we're gonna have money for
something let's just work on a recipe so
we go to Dave's house every day and our
day was just like you know we finish up
work go to Dave's house uh you know
start cooking up food in this kitchen
you know buy just the ingredients and
cook it and uh we might have done this
for like
five months where we just worked on a
recipe wow yeah yeah and then one thing
the recipe was kind of done right and
there's only so much you can do and so
we're like sitting there at Dave's house
like all right well we have the food but
like what do we do like we have no money
you know like how do we how do we get
this out there like how do we sell this
to people right so uh our friend Tommy's
like uh well uh what if we try like a
pop-up you know we could do some some
sort of like pop-ups pop up somewhere
another one of our friends I was like
yes like I know a lot of people that do
that it's like they'll pop up in places
they'll wrap their stuff up at night and
then they'll just leave so we're like
all right well we could we could
probably get together a pop-up right so
we started scrapping together a little
bit of money dude and uh we literally
Noble subscribed together 900 that's all
we can get they took his last check 300
bucks I had like a few hundred bucks
saved up Tommy's like I'll put in the
rest whatever we need so we went to uh
Target you know we bought like a little
canopy and we went on Craigslist and
whenever we want a little Friar we took
some tables from our parents houses and
some chairs and uh we just popped up one
day yeah yeah Tommy uh linked up with
this guy that he used to work with and
he offered to give us like one little
spot in a parking lot it was literally
one spot in a public parking lot wow so
we set up our shop over there
posted on social media that were open
and our first night went like 40 bucks
obviously it's just a bunch of kids in a
parking lot uh and then uh you know we
just you know started like pushing on
social media you know we knew we had a
good product we started you know we'd
run around the block screaming we got
chicken we got chicken we were literally
screaming hey we got chicken come buy
some chicken you know what I mean uh and
then we got noticed we got noticed we
got written up in an article uh we got
written up in either LA and uh this guy
wrote an insane article about as far
away what year is this this is 2017.
what the [ __ ] yes yeah yeah and then do
we get to the yeah we get to the pop-up
the next day after I lived here in 2017.
yeah it was on Hollywood Boulevard dude
it was right on uh Hollywood and
Normandy yeah do you know where Jumbo's
Clown Room is yeah yeah it was literally
across the street we'd go to the line
we'd go to the jumbos line and hand out
sandals to people okay you'll come get
some chicken yeah and then like see
there was like 90 people in our pop-ups
like waiting for us when we got there
what and that was early that was like
the first week we were there yeah it was
like five days in yeah okay so you guys
get a buzz yeah obviously you're kind of
like the Talk of the Town yeah when for
where's your first brick and mortar
mortar location where's that at that's
on Western yeah close by it was like a
mile away yeah so I think pretty early
on we realized seven months into it yeah
and then we realized like yo this is
pretty big you know like if we're pretty
responsible with this like we could
really blow it up and we could be really
professional so we started getting
really disciplined and every dollar we
make we'd invest back into the pop-up
until we couldn't anymore and then every
other dollar after that kind of just
went to saving up to like get a brick
and mortar
hey we got to stop the interview to tell
you about our folks at my bookie that's
right baby Super Bowl is coming well you
know in a month or so we got the
playoffs right now you could get those
future bets in on who you think out of
this uh barrage of teams that made it to
the playoffs is going to win the Super
Bowl you could bet player props we can
go NBA action on them so much ways to
make money with all the sports going on
and you could do it all at my bookie
right now if you go to my bookie and you
sign up for a new account use the promo
code bootleg and they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
you know what's dope about my bookie not
only can you bet on your favorite sports
but you could also get a little
Blackjack going little slot machines in
that name a little roulette yeah me so
much ways to get paid on my bookie the
most important thing is though if you
sign up and you use the promo code
bootleg at my bookie go to my bookie my
bookie my bookie my bookie use the promo
code bootleg and they're gonna match
your first deposit up to one thousand
dollars right [ __ ] now
listen I'm a degenerate but I'm pretty
good at this
I've been using my bookie for like 10
years all right very trusted they're the
best trust me they are the [ __ ] best
wherever you're at if you're watching
this you can sign up for my bookie
account one more time that's my book you
use the promo code bootleg and they will
double your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars free [ __ ] money
let's get to it all right boys back to
the interview so at this time you have
the sauce [ __ ] the sauce concoction
yeah yeah the fries yeah we got all that
down every early yeah yeah and kept it
at the same until what I like about it
too is like uh you guys have a simple
menu I feel like all the great spots is
like it's not what I think this when you
go to In-N-Out Burger exactly they got
Burgers you go to Dave's Hot Chicken how
do you want your chicken you wanna you
wanna chicken finger or you want it on a
slider which one do you want that's
exactly so you guys don't overthink it
but it's it is kind of interesting like
at what point in time
does it because you guys are a staple
now
when did you start to feel that as like
owners of the business where you were
kind of like oh we're kind of like a
part of the food culture in L.A now like
it's funny man it happened really early
you know at the parking lot all my
friends started talking about like damn
you guys blew up and like yeah yeah man
just people yeah I think we're seeing uh
our parents there uh looking at the
pop-up seeing all the people in line the
response of the food
um there's this funny story we like to
tell there was a night you know because
we'd open up at seven o'clock you'd have
to get your order in within like an hour
to two hours because we'd sell out
really fast
so we'd have like people like running in
at night like yo you guys got any more
chicken I'm like no one time some guy
was like bro he's like can I buy some
crumbs off you guys and we're like
crumbs were like dude what is this like
how serious is this like chicken
addiction to people that's right they
want to buy crumbs and from there we
were like dude like this is like this is
big dude like this is not just like
something small like we definitely have
to be disciplined we definitely have to
make the Right Moves or else we don't
want to mess this up you know what I
mean was there any uh because are there
any people from Nashville that are like
yo you guys are appropriating the
Nashville chick culture well like a very
slight amount actually I feel like you
guys might have some haters like you
know what's funny is when I look at our
IG because I handle the IG you there is
a overwhelming amount of people that are
like why are you guys not in Nashville
like you know we want we want you guys
in Nashville because I think what
happens is if you're younger you're
going up in Nashville yeah there's a lot
of Nashville hot chicken places right of
course but you grow up on it so it's
nothing new to you well I also feel like
there's an LA style of hot chicken
exactly that you guys kind of like I
feel like there's Nashville hot chicken
but then there's like La Hot Chicken
yeah like La Nashville Hot Chicken it's
like its own it's like its own sub genre
it's almost like really just to talk
about if you think of like Mexican food
there's like styles of Mexican food
exactly you know what I mean like if you
go to Texas it's not gonna be the same
as if you go to exactly yeah exactly so
a lot of the young people over there
some of the older people might be like
you know some of the people also
competition here might be like yeah but
the people over there like dude we want
it like this is Young this is cool we're
not used to a hot chicken brown like
this and we want to try it out here yeah
I mean there's other uh I think I I mean
I've had a bunch of that I try if I see
a hot chicken place my kid makes me try
it it's all it's all like he's like yeah
let's try it and there's been some
terrible places there's been some decent
places as well
um but for you guys
how many locations are we at now uh 105.
105. yeah yeah and you guys started this
in a parking lot five years ago with
nine hundred dollars and it's a
franchise model yeah
105. how many states are we in uh
uh oh I would say maybe like uh 40 of
the states I know we're in New York
we're in Texas Florida Illinois Florida
uh Wisconsin uh Wisconsin Canada Dubai
yeah we're in Dubai where these are in
Dubai yeah we have two stores in Dubai
One in qataria yeah we're pretty out
there man we have a really good team so
I think so what happened is um obviously
after we realized the brand is really
big in the pop-up we started saving our
money our third Founder's older brother
uh who was you know he was he was a
pretty chill businessman at the time
he's like look I'll invest with you guys
I'll kind of come in as like an older
person to help you guys out a little bit
and we could make this a storefront so
we kind of you know invested our money
with him we made it a storefront uh
which also blew up I mean the store was
obviously bigger than the pop-up because
now we had like you know it was like
already there too yeah exactly right so
seven or six months into that after
seeing that there's a lot of CopyCat
Brands there's a lot of you know just
chicken brands in general they're
everywhere yeah you start to really
realize like it's not about who has the
best food anymore right like the best
food is like yeah you gotta have the
best it's also subjective exactly that's
the thing is like all right some people
love Dave some people love someone else
but the brand that can really take this
Nationwide and be the first brand to
take hot chicken into every other state
and do it right and do it in a
consistent way that's the brand that's
going to win this so we kind of from
there started looking into like
partnering up with people that have done
it before right uh and we met
um this guy named John Davis and Bill
Phelps and there John Davis is a
Hollywood producer a really big invest
in a lot of like different brands he
invested in wetzel's pretzels and Blaze
Pizza and things like that and Bill was
the founder of wessels and then one of
the main investors of Blaze so these
guys have done it they've done the
franchise thing they've grown
restaurants and scaled them yeah and uh
you know there's a lot of people that
have done that but also we had like
really dope chemistry with these guys I
mean we felt like there were four yeah
we feel like we've known them our whole
lives you know so
when we partner up with them that's when
it really took off it really took off
yeah because they brought in the people
necessary to grow the brand they brought
in the operations people necessarily
keep the food consistency you know they
bring in experienced franchisees where
you're not just selling to anybody
you're selling to Big groups right that
have an infrastructure and they have a
lot of different restaurants already and
they're going to expand in their
territory really fast really efficiently
right that's how you ha that's how you
could have such a big growth but yet
maintain and not open 100 stores but
then close 40 right later yeah so we're
continuing to go I think we have 700 uh
units committed to so we have 700 stores
sold so by the end of yeah and but you
know in a few years there'll be 700
Dave's Hot chickens so
if I'm an um an entrepreneur and I'm
like I want to open a dayside chicken
uh-huh
what do I how much money do I need
it's funny we look at like the
experience you have and yeah it's less
about the money yeah so so like because
you know sometimes you'll see like oh
you could get a Burger King but you need
like uh 750 000 liquid or a million
dollars yeah yeah it's it's an
interesting uh process now so the first
thing we would look at is what territory
you're looking about right so let's say
you're looking to buy um Texas okay okay
like where in Texas and what experience
do you have in that area in Texas how
many stores or restaurants do you
currently run in Texas what's your team
like what are your store you got to vet
the people it's not about the money
because anybody's looking at the table
with money but they might [ __ ] your
brand up yeah anybody has money but if
like if you're like dude I got like you
know I own a car mechanic shop and I got
a billion dollars on Deck okay but how
are you gonna run a restaurant you know
you have a car mechanic shop it's not
the same concept right have you guys had
any issues yet with any of the 105
locations where like maybe the quality
because you know sometimes with those
franchises you you guys aren't as in
control of like if the chicken gets made
right of course have you guys had to
like sit down and talk to somebody like
hey look guys you guys I mean in the
expansion expansion process there has to
be some speakers right yeah man of
course there's always speed bumps but I
think again that's when it comes down to
having a good enough team where you can
you know it quickly spot the problems
quickly have the communication to fix it
quickly so that it doesn't spread it
doesn't become a bigger problem right
and again have a team in place that can
even before the problems get there can
predetermine what the problems might be
to kind of make sure that they don't
happen so it just again comes down to
your team because if you don't have the
right team and you open 20 stores it
could be a cluster you know what I mean
like it could be all over the place
whereas if you have a really disciplined
experience team 100 stores is kind of
just like it's easy to run it's like a
well-oiled machine has anybody online
figured out your recipe yet
no no I think Dave's the only I get I
get chefs telling me like man that thing
is impossible to like recreate no
because like you'll see like people be
like this is how you make Dave's sauce
or yeah have you seen those tick tocks
or any of that stuff on YouTube yeah
yeah but they'd ever get it right no I
don't think so I mean it took you five
months to come up with a yeah but yeah
and I think the chances of getting that
uh spice mix recipe right because
there's so many like different grams in
there so there's like 50 grams of
cayenne so even if you mess up one to
two grams it's not gonna we had a
challenge at my house uh in December
where we got the the really hot one the
most hot the reaper oh yeah the reaper
so my my son bought like five of them
and everybody had to take a bite and he
he's the only one who finished one that
[ __ ] is
ridiculous right comfortably it's bad
it's bad yeah and [ __ ] been
eating that [ __ ] yeah man it's crazy
they go through it bro it messed my
stomach up for a while yeah I can't I
can't go above medium now no I love that
Medium is where I'm at it's my sunshine
give me that medium and I love the sauce
has anyone gotten the sauce right
not that like no we bro the sauce is so
good the sauce is hard to make man I'm
not gonna lie yeah it's really complex
yeah but you know what's what's
hilarious is we used to have these Army
and ladies that work for us and they
they one of them moved the sauce recipe
she knew yeah and when they left the job
every chicken spot was recorded yeah
they were like Contracting her oh she
was selling the secret sauce yeah oh
five year deal come play with us and
it's funny because
it is kind of like an Armenian Rand
industry in L.A most hot chicken places
are Armenian owned uh I wonder why I
wonder am I tripping you're not man I
don't think Alan raises but I think most
of the spots yeah it is Armenian owned
our means are like they're quick to
catch on yeah they're quick to jump on
things I mean we're Armenian we saw it
quick we jumped on it right yeah
um but every all of my favorite
restaurants are by the way are Armenian
owns you guys got it figured out in the
[ __ ] Valley I feel we're pretty good
with food man we have a good palette but
I think another thing is like
when we got into it there was almost
like this genuine intention of like
let's create this really really good
food that we could serve to people and
be proud of it and you know join it on
this trend but not for the sake of the
trend just to like because we love this
food too and we want to make our best
version of it of course and Dave being a
chef he was very passionate about it
right whereas uh and not everybody but a
lot of other people because that's like
a cash grab it's like this exactly yeah
it's like oh hot chickens in it's
selling right now oh they got a line
what are they making hot chicken cool
throw it on the menu
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to uh stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah blue chill gets your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the blue shoe
right to your [ __ ] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[ __ ] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [ __ ] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[ __ ] young lady you bring her to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [ __ ]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not gonna perform it's
not it's not going to perform how you'd
like it to but you know how it will
perform if you're on that [ __ ]
Bluetooth
you're going to put in a [ __ ] Luka
donkic 61 Point [ __ ] performance on
that [ __ ] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview is there anybody else's hot
chicken that you've tried that you like
I love Holland race yeah
I love them dude that's what I've heard
I've heard I want to try Helen raised
because I've heard uh my boy estad who's
Armenian you guys might know him yeah we
do he's a homie yeah great school as
hell uh s Dot's like yo you got to go to
Holland race Holland's fire yeah and I
assumed it was Armenian owned because s
dot always puts me on those spots yeah
and he's like it's not Armenian you know
it's good if I'm telling you it's like
if it's not Army you know you like you
know it's good no look they're they're
another one of those Brands where like
the guys just genuinely loves food and
he loves chicken yeah he's a chef he
does it for the food right and you know
that because he hasn't expanded like
crazy he looks loves the food I think
that's dope you guys can acknowledge
that too you know yeah there's a lot
dude we love chicken man you gotta love
all kinds of chicken and you know
especially when we're working on the
recipe all we did is eat different
changes there used to be a tent right
here on Vineland and Magnolia in the
Walgreens parking lot and their [ __ ] was
solid I don't know what happened to them
oh that was my cousin no I'm just
kidding it might have been I don't even
know it could have been um okay so how
so correct me Drake is is a part of like
some of the locations or is going to be
a part of the locations or he's not part
of location so what happened is um
because I saw the headline about Drake
getting involved with some Dave's Hot
Chicken he has uh ownership in the
entire like in the entire brand right so
Drake owns a piece of Dave's Hot Chicken
a very small piece of Dave's Hot Chicken
and he's also like a smokesman for the
brand so he'll help us with like
different promotions that we do
um for his birthday we linked up with
him and we gave out like free sandwiches
to everybody that came to the store how
did that happen he's just a fan he's in
La he loves it yeah man he he loves the
chicken and he's a super dope guy and
he's an amazing person and uh you know
after hearing about the story uh I think
he just wanted to kind of you know be a
part of the brand and help out any way
he can so it's been super cool man and
Drake calls you answer
he calls I answer you're gonna be like
how can we get you involved man oh yeah
it's like what up dragon let's get you
no I'm saying if Drake reaches out it's
like he's the biggest [ __ ] artist you
got to get him involved yeah like uh it
was kind of like surreal to us to even
hear that that was a possibility right
where somebody's like because you
imagine if you're in the parking lot
with 900 and somebody can talk to you
yeah and they're like hey two or three
years from now Drake's gonna offer to be
a part of your company you're gonna be
like all right dude like order your food
and get out you know what I mean you're
not gonna believe them but you know it's
it's wild I mean look you guys are
definitely on your way to being like the
next big franchise 700 locations already
in the works yeah I think they said
we're one of the fastest growing chains
in in like U.S America yeah the food is
amazing well no I mean it's been five
years since we were in a parking lot
yeah and that shit's crazy yeah I didn't
realize that I thought you guys were at
least around like I was like oh maybe it
was like an LA thing for like 10 years
and now it's finally like five years
dude yeah dude it's happened overnight
yeah it was like an overnight thing
sometimes it's still surreal to us you
know I think the company why there's
like three or four thousand employees we
have and you know what would be some of
the like uh business side of this that
you've kind of because anytime you scale
that fast yeah you go through like a
learning curve of course you [ __ ] up you
adjust you get it together what are some
of the things that you learned on you
know for anybody who's an up-and-coming
business person or an up and coming
restaurant owner uh what are some of the
things that you kind of had to learn on
the fly or some of the mistakes that you
made that you guys kind of yeah you know
you want to go first you guys can kind
of share it kind of you know because a
lot a lot of people might be watching
this who have a food truck yeah you know
who might want to scale and get a brick
and mortar or
I don't know bro uh I mean I would
definitely say uh partners are very
important you know I think a lot of
entrepreneurs when they start a business
they're afraid to bring in other
partners because there's this fear that
somebody's gonna come over and take over
your business and you're going to lose
percentage and things like that uh I
think what we found is
you need to find somebody that you trust
somebody that's experienced in the line
of work you're in and you need to be
able to let people help you grow your
brand right so there was this
interesting thing is like would you
rather have 100 of a grape or you know
50 of a watermelon for sure for sure
right so for me the most important
lesson has been bringing in the right
Partners people you have good chemistry
with people you can grow the company
with people that have the same goals as
you right because you can bring in
partners that have different goals and
that's that's going to mess everything
up so for me the biggest thing is as a
business owner
it's okay to bring in Partners it's okay
to partner up with people that are
big in the line of work you're in that
can help you out yeah I think that
that's something like you said I think
that's some pride [ __ ] I think at times
you know especially in the music
industry people are always like yeah
it's like dude
partnering with the right people if you
can make a billion dollars but you know
it's like it's like most people would
rather make a million dollars and say
they own their everything than make like
500 million interesting it's like dude
to me it's like and there's just like
things like oh yeah well they want to
work we do make money but it's like well
that's obvious dude this is business
people are in business to make money you
know people get in a position to make
money if you're gonna be at that mindset
like yeah people just want to make well
obviously dude but the thing is you want
to make money together right you so you
partner up and you gotta help each other
yeah man it has to be you got to bring
in expertise that like I can't do yeah
yeah I think that franchise model is
like a whole like that's a whole new
world that's like a world that I'm sure
is like yeah man because it's it's I
mean because there's this thing about it
it's like right when you're like you
feel this sense of ownership to the
brand because you're a Founder you
started it right and then a franchisee
is a person that believed in your brand
enough to you know we're doing 10 store
deals minimum by the time they invest in
these 10 stores each store is uh you
know let's say 700 000 build out there
so anybody who wants to start with y'all
they gotta commit to 10. it's about a 10
story commitment yeah wow so they need
to be experienced enough to handle those
10 stores right yeah and by the time
they open those 10 stores they've
invested so much money into your brand
that now they feel a sense of ownership
where they also feel like hey this is my
idea I feel like you guys should do this
so you also have to find again this
balance of
this is not just my brand anymore you
know I have franchisees that have
invested as much time and money as I
have into this place yeah it's their
brand too yeah and I got their own 10
locations yeah and I have to respect
their opinion because they're also
living off of this brand so if I don't
listen to what they have to say and I
just run it however we want and they're
not happy it's not going to keep
expanding right so it's all like this
balancing it act it's all about like um
you know understanding the people around
you and making sure like everybody can
win hey we got to stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our family
at hard Dean that's right hard Dean lost
Vegas the craziest dispensary in the
world the number one dispensary in the
United States let alone in Las Vegas all
right maybe you're hitting Vegas with
your friends your girlfriends whatever
maybe it's a bachelor party whatever's
going on you're going to go watch the
Raiders suck [ __ ] whatever it is make
sure you pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas
tell them I sent you they got the
craziest selection of Premium cannabis
I've ever seen in my [ __ ] life the
pre-rolls the cartridges the Edibles the
flower all top notch all the best the
bud tenders are so friendly it smells
great it smells so good inside a Jardine
that they have their own Harding
signature scent candle
see I sniffed that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed all right so go follow them right
now Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot
him a follow get all the details you
need you can get you some of this fly
ass Harding merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview
who's been outside of Drake obviously
who's who you think is like your guys's
like most famous fan Drake aside because
we know Drake's an owner now but like
who do you guys know is just always just
getting chicken well Brothers delivered
to the studio or an athlete or we have a
lot of uh actually a couple of our
investors are Samuel L Jackson's one of
our investors also so Samuel Jackson
owns a little bit uh also of Dave's Hot
Chicken it's Dave's Hot [ __ ] I
dude I keep saying he needs to make our
training videos just come on he's like I
want these [ __ ] tenders but uh
Michael Strahan is another one of our
investors
um
um Maria Shriver wow yeah so there's
like a lot of people and then on the
customer side I mean dude the amount of
people we've seen come to Dave's Hot
Chicken everybody yeah it's I'm just
blown us away dude like Eddie Murphy's
and like people just yeah the crazy like
people that we grew up idolizing and we
were like dude are they really at Dave's
right now are they really posting how
Samuel Jackson get involved just being a
fan uh through Billet like again we when
we brought in Bill and John they kind of
had this network of people that work
with me yeah people that trusted them
because they'd already done this twice
right so for them it was just easy to
reach out and like hey this is uh we
think this is a great concept so we
think you guys should be involved right
and on top of that they see the brand
and a lot and the cool thing about
Dave's is data needs to do a lot of
convincing because most people are like
oh yeah oh yeah yeah I'm in you know
yeah so you know it was really cool for
us so now when you guys see another
they're so like there's a company like
Raising Cane's right been doing this for
a long time as well yeah they haven't
expanded like crazy do you guys uh try
to like read like like because you know
sometimes you guys are in the same
industry you guys are both selling
chicken different types of chicken yeah
but braising canes is going crazy Dave's
not chicken is going crazy do you guys
ever try to like reach out to the
because I the owner of that company is
super cool I always see him doing his
reviews and [ __ ] yeah
you know what man I wouldn't mind it all
man because I if you guys did a [ __ ]
Raising Cane's Dave's collab sandwich
for like and it was at both locations
raising Dave's oh my God it would melt
the [ __ ] food World hey if you're
watching this let's let's make it happen
raisin Dave's that would be insane dude
like I I love all chicken and I love all
chicken brands and we heard this really
cool the the owner of hotville another
chicken brand told us this one time they
said there's millions of people in the
world and all of them eat two to three
times a day so you should never feel
like competition with another of course
because there so many mouths to feed
it's not like if they they're they might
eat at one place early in the morning
and either yours in the middle of the
day so you know I mean so tell us
there's not really like oh that's our
competition and you love all of them I
love Raising Cane's I eat them when I
see it you know and so I mean both of
y'all blowing the [ __ ] up for sure yeah
and they're much older than us too for
sure they've been around a long time
yeah dude they're in the like I think 30
they've been a while yeah I lived in
Vegas in 2010 and they were there so
they've been around forever yeah you
guys were growing that which is crazy
yeah we're a young brand and to even be
compared with some of these like older
brands that have been around for a while
it's flattering to us dude uh you guys
are in some cool cities but what is the
city that you guys like want to be in or
a place or a country that you think
would be kind of cool uh Dave you know I
like Tokyo yeah Tokyo Dave's insane
Tokyo since we were cooking at his house
he's like one day we could be in Tokyo
yeah that'd be a fly assessment it would
be cool yeah we need to find a good
friendship what about our media
Army is amazing we had an opportunity we
had a a person that was interested in
franchising in Armenia but uh I might
wait on that one a little longer you
know towards the end of the story you
know finish it off in Armenia yes Tokyo
would be fly as [ __ ] though Tokyo would
be great yeah just everywhere bro so
what do you now that the business is
booming you guys got Partners what is
your guys's like daily or weekly hat
like like you probably have a lot I mean
I don't know how busy you are but what
are you guys into besides [ __ ]
printing money and making chicken
yeah I still work for the I I'm I have
the CBO position so I work for the
corporate company so you're still very
active yeah and we still have 10 of our
own stores so Dave runs like a lot of
our stores with kids the language can
store yours yeah yeah that's our story
that's our spot yeah and Sherman Oak
Glendale is also are so they have a lot
of source one and I'll I oversee a lot
of the you know branding stuff marketing
anything that's like you know visual
deal with a lot of franchisees so my
day-to-day stuff I still do a lot of
stuff but when I have free time I like
the golfing you know yeah what about you
classic stuff would you guys do a second
restaurant concept yeah we're we're
working on it yeah we're plotting it out
not a restaurant uh closer uh we're
we're we're cutting something up
something's coming we're cooking
something up it's in the process are you
coming up with the recipe yeah together
same thing always same Cooks in the
kitchen different concepts so we'll see
how so there'll be a New Concept coming
soon yeah yeah once once yeah yeah so
because Dave's is it's so big and it's
blowing up so fast it still requires
like a lot of it of course you don't
want to like leave this amazing concept
and go do something else quite yet but
you know you keep it on the back burner
you develop it and then when the time is
right you just open it hey we got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
family at Odd Socks that's right the
most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist and shout
out to all you rappers and people who be
pouring your lean into this [ __ ]
some Mountain Dew Baja Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview uh what's your favorite
thing to cook at home at home to be
honest bro I don't really cook too much
at home all my cooking was done and like
when I was working in restaurants but so
let's say you got are you are you
married yeah okay so let's say your wife
is like babe I need you to cook dinner
tonight yeah I need you to it's our
anniversary but I want you to cook what
are you cooking bro I like I like
barbecue like Army and barbecue I like
steak or some course okay so I'll I have
a fire pit in my backyard I'll just
start the fire and then so you grill on
the on the fire pit yeah yeah
you got like a you got like one of those
wood pellet grills no it's just you know
I have you have like actual pit yeah
it's more like just like a bowl and then
I I put uh like wood my own wood in
there and then I just let the fire cool
down and then just cook over it what's
he best at cooking outside dude this guy
can cook anything mine uh yeah this guy
makes some dope steaks for sure uh we
used to have thanksgivings at his house
and like oh potato salad this guy makes
a bomb potato salad we made potato salad
for our partner one time uh John Davis
like three and a half four years ago and
every time he sees his life he's like
potato salad yeah we gotta get that
potato salad on the menu so it's been
the crazy because now you guys have come
into some real money very successful
what has been your guys's most each one
of your guys's most outlandish random
purchase
is it a car is it a [ __ ] comic book
what is it yeah I mean we're pretty
disciplined man we don't run too crazy
with uh money I bought I I buy a couple
sport cars that's what I like I like
sport cars like yeah I go to sport cars
Dave uh all right it's about like a
crazy off-road car yeah like it's a
Toyota Tacoma but like oh you got
tricked out TRD Pro I tricked it out
yeah I got a tent on top like well you
know those Tacomas you could customize
yeah I think it's like the most
customizable car yeah what we do is we
we get into very random Hobbies every
now and then you like to off-road
off-road we go snowboarding yeah like
yeah we'll get everything fishing we're
getting some crazy stuff too so do you
have a tricked out Toyota as well nah
man I had a tricked out uh AMG GTR that
was pretty badass and then it got
rear-ended so I'm uh I'm shopping for
something new right now yeah dude crazy
I love that car look man you guys are
killing it I love the chicken
um I look forward to buying more of it
thank you man that's great yeah he's
like yeah us too especially because you
go to the location that's always over
here yeah the chicken is great man I
love what y'all are doing and I think
it's dope just like a five-year I mean
look it's about what what what what
month in uh 17 was it in May so coming
up on six years yeah so you guys have
had a hell of a come up man
congratulations thank you so much man
it's been it's been cool man we're still
in the working process you know it's
still have a lot of work to do so we're
trying not to chill out yet you know
what I mean we're trying to stay in work
mode chances are
if you're in a city and you're watching
this you can go buy some Dave's Hot
Chicken soon even if it's not there yet
it'll get there Nashville coming soon
let's hope man I'd love it that'd be
crazy a little Tennessee I love it yeah
there it is boys Dave's Hot Chicken
appreciate you guys for pulling up man
thank you man thank you yes sir